voici philippe favier qui raconte ses
tableaux à l'interview pinceau l'art
sans pincettes ses lunettes
yves favier bonsoir enfin arte de
saint-etienne ton papa de boîte de nuit
c'est ça entre autre vie la réserve a
impressionné c'est pas dépaysés ça va
pas trop non il ya encore quelques
d'ordures qui peut craquer
et après comment tu te retrouvais la
villa médicis
[Applaudissements]
qui c'est passé de belles choses de
plusieurs plusieurs jurys de belles
rencontres soulage m'étonnerait il s'est
passé
voilà quatre mois c'est à la fois c'est
vrai et c'est faux mais c'est quelque
chose un peu délicat abordé par ce qu'il
faut mais en fait en effet savoir
exactement pourquoi j'y suis resté type
de tempête est le nouveau nom pourquoi
non parce que non parce que c'est pas
c'est pas intéressant ce que je puis
dire c'est un lieu magnifique il y à là
bas certaines personnes très bien que
certaines faire ça dit que peut-être je
suis tombé sur une année difficile
on a compris alors en 82 au moment de
l'éclatement de la figuration libre
salle et les grands formats bariolés
souhaitait arriver avec des signatures
délicate des oeuvres comme ça les 10
puces yale on a pu dire c'était une
réaction c'était pourquoi tu faisais ça
à cette époque là où tout est
contemporain finalement été tentée par
par l' inverse
je crois que moi ce qui m'a qui m'a
troublé lorsque j'étais étudiant six
cadets les choses que l'on voyait qui
nous touche r
en classe de la peinture américaine des
préventes format les écologues
et sans doute je me suis trouvé d'emblée
essoufflé par ces grandes choses
mon attitude à ce moment là était de
tenter dans le monde
minuscule point de faire des choses à
mes dix mentions encore des petites
choses par fenêtre j'ai tenté de faire
des grandes choses et à l'époque je n'y
arrive pas mais je veux dire
qu'actuellement je je me koning travail
vers pas ça c'est autre chose et tu
faisais quoi alors ces petites choses
c'était quoi ces petites choses au sein
ce qu'était c'était de toute petite
chose qui sauve un film des bagatelles
et bagatelles pour un massacre il celui
d'hier puisque c'étaient des petites
scènes de guerre des choses au stylo
bille sur du papier journal
alors après dans les années 85 87 café
des peintures sur verre que tu enchâssé
dans des boîtes de sardines ajouté c'est
pourquoi tous les détails ça ressemble à
quoi
je reste avec ça ressemble à des
talismans de peinture je n'ai pas avancé
jamais vraiment quand elle est sur les
quatre au début voilà notre escarcelle
un petit peu sacré deux fois ci je suis
arrivé je pense en tous les cas pour mac
certaines de ses peintures de sang
répandu et théâtre le plus cher au
millimètre carré tu veux c'est voyager
du stade et ça faisait paris parisiana
c'est à dire comme la boîte de nuit de
l'hôtel bern de ses peintures salle
parisienne à 7 que que j'aime le plus ce
qui me touche mais pourquoi alors après
tu es maintenant en 89 s'est passé au
grand format certes a fait des des
objets sur des fonds noirs sérigraphié
des objets très simple comme ça dépôt
des crues d'état
pourquoi dans cette mouture est dit tout
le monde va m'en parler mais c'est
normal parce qu'après avoir fait toutes
ces petites choses tellement
révolutionnaire à l'époque de la
figuration libre mais seul coup tu
passes au grand format alors pourquoi
sans doute que je devais d'une part
avoir un peu marre
pour écouter le cadre du petit format et
aussi par ailleurs parce que ce que j'ai
envie de continuer mon travail et mon
travail c'est de chercher d'autres sur
des charges doit y trouver moins cher et
maintenant tu vas faire quoi
maintenant je vais vers des formes un
peu plus grand mais parler uniquement de
formats c'est peut-être restreindre des
choses alors je continue mes recherches
abandonne un peu les les objets pour
travailler davantage sur l'espace je
reviens petit peu aux as qui n'était pas
peut-être pas très visible dans les
premiers travaux qui est une quête de
l'espace en questionnement de ce tout ce
bois silencieux qui est l'espace le mur
donc je continue dans cette franchement
c'était un pur débarquer
on repart pas beaucoup de choses parce
que je connaissais je n'essaie pas grand
chose et dans toutes choses m'ont touché
ira non comme ça ce serait oublier trop
ouais je sais que maintenant je suis
touché par toujours et depuis longtemps
par des gens comme trier par bolt
soulage qui me breaks l'ont énormément
la fois des tracteurs et des spacieux
serait qui s'était passé du clavier
si j'étais pas finie prévu et je serai
là son très prétentieux je serai je
trouve malheureux qui devrait bien ces
mélomanes dambre par un tableau
[Musique]
le dernier j'ai mis trois ans à oui
j'écoute de la musique quand tu parles
non j'écoute j'écoute la radio j'aime
bien entendre des voix
déjà j'aime bien savoir que des gens
existent tout le monde alors je suis
surtout des bavardages sur la définition
suivante équipe tactiquement rien
n'était je sens que des gens existent
touristique ça vaut combien grand fort
mal en ce moment
ça serait doivent à grains favorables
montrant ses campings ça pas de problème
avec les marchands j'en ai eu un gros
mais j'en ai plus chez yvon lambert
suivi on peut voir des choses de temps
ce moment là bas oui quelques petites
choses pas les toutes dernières parce
que je travaille dessus
ça va être un petit peu de temps à venir
on les verra plus tard pour arrêter des
choses tête de la finale qui n'abuse
c'était peut-être ça sert à quoi la
peinture peut-être ça doit servir à dire
que les femmes ne sont pas que
ça tu penses que tu te sers de la
peinture c'est la peinture qui se
servent de toit aux sans doute que je
vais me sers de la peinture je mangerai
pour ne pas être trop angoissé par être
malheureux je m'en sers pas pour entrer
en contact avec les gens qui ont des
voix une [ __ ] je m'en sers peut-être
mal pour l'instant
l'échangé devient une définition de toi
pas dans le dictionnaire ou sur tard sur
ta pierre tombale passant les clarifier
favier deux points quoi est ce qu'ils
souhaiteraient qu'on écrive une une date
le plus loin possible demain et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de il a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux